In most topics you have to get
pretty advanced before you
start addressing the
philosophically interesting
things, but in chemistry it
just starts right from the
get-go with what's arguably
the most philosophically
interesting part of the whole
topic, and that's the atom.
And the idea of the atom, as
philosophers long ago, and you
could look it up on the
different philosophers who
first philosophized about it,
they said, hey, you know, if I
started off with, I don't know,
if I started off with an
apple, and I just kept cutting
the apple -- let me draw a
nice looking apple just so
it doesn't look just
like a heart .
There you go.
You have a nice looking apple,
And you just kept cutting it,
smaller and smaller pieces.
So eventually, you get a piece
so small, so tiny, that you
can't cut it anymore.
And I'm sure some of these
philosophers went out there
with a knife and tried to do
it and they just felt that,
oh, if I could just get my knife
a little bit sharper, I
could cut it again and again.
So it's a completely
philosophical construct, which
frankly, in a lot of ways, isn't
too different to how the
atom is today.
It's really just a mental
abstraction that allows us to
describe a lot of observations
we see in the universe.
But anyway, these philosophers
said, well, at some point we
think that there's going to be
some little part of an apple
that they won't be able
to divide anymore.
And they called that an atom.
And it doesn't just have to just
be for an apple they said
this is true for any substance
or any element to that you
encounter in the universe.
And so the word atom is really
Greek for uncuttable.
Uncuttable or indivisible.
Now we know that it actually is
cuttable and even though it
is not a trivial thing, it's
not the smallest form of
matter we know.
We now know that an atom is
made up of other more
fundamental particles.
And let me write that.
So the we have the neutron.
And I'll draw in a second how
they all fit together and the
structure of an atom.
We have a neutron.
We have a proton.
And we have electrons.
Electrons.
And you might already be
familiar with this if you look
at old videos about atomic
projects, you'll see a drawing
that looks something
like this.
Let me see if I can draw one.
So you'll have something
like that.
And you'll have these things
spinning around
that look like this.
They have orbits that
look like that.
And maybe something that
looks like that.
And the general notion behind
these kind of nuclear drawings
-- and I'm sure that they
still show up at some
government defense labs or
something like that -- is that
you have a nucleus at the
center of an atom.
You have a nucleus at the
And we know that a nucleus
has neutrons and protons.
Neutrons and protons.
And we'll talk a little bit more
about which elements have
how many neutrons and
how many protons.
And then orbiting, and I'm going
to use the word orbit
right now, although we'll learn
in about two minutes
that the word orbit is actually
the incorrect or even
the mentally incorrect way
of visualizing what
an electron is doing.
But the old idea was that you
have these electrons that are
orbiting around the nucleus very
similar to the way the
Earth orbits around the
Sun or the moon
orbits around the Earth.
And it's been shown that
that's actually
a very wrong way.
And when we cover quantum
mechanics we'll learn why this
doesn't work, what are the
contradictions that emerge
when you try to model an
electron like a planet going
around the Sun.
But this was kind of the
original idea, and frankly I
think this is kind of the idea
that is the most mainstream
way of viewing an atom.
Now, I said an atom is
philosophically interesting.
Why is it philosophically
interesting?
Because what we now view as the
accepted way of viewing an
atom really starts to blur the
line between our physical
reality and everything in the
world is just information, and
there really isn't any such
thing as true matter or true
particles as the way we define
them in our everyday life.
You know, for me a particle,
oh, it looks
like a grain of sand.
I can pick it up, touch it.
While a wave, that could be like
a soundwave. It could be
just this change in
energy over time.
But we'll learn, especially when
we do quantum mechanics,
that it all gets jumbled up as
we start approaching the
scales or the size of an atom.
Anyway, I said this was an
incorrect way of doing it.
What's the correct way?
So it turns out-- this is a
picture, not a picture really,
this is also a depiction.
So it's an interesting question,
what I just said.
How can you have a picture
of an atom?
Because is actually turns out
that most wavelengths of
light, especially the visible
wavelengths of light, are much
larger than the size
of an atom.
Everything else we
quote-unquote, observe in
life, it's by reflected light.
But all of a sudden when you're
dealing with an atom,
reflected light you could almost
view it as too big, or
too blunt of an instrument with
which to observe an atom.
Anyway, this is a depiction
of a helium atom.
A helium atom has two protons
and two neutrons.
Or at least this helium
atom has two
protons and two neutrons.
And the way they depict it here
in the nucleus, right
there, maybe these are the two--
I'm assuming they're
using red for proton and
purple for neutron.
Purple seems like more
of a neutral color.
And they're sitting at the
center of this atom.
And then this whole haze around
there, those are the
two electrons that helium
has, or that at least
this helium atom has.
Maybe you could gain or
lose an electron.
But these are the
two electrons.
And you say, hey, Sal, how can
two electrons be this blur
that's kind of smeared
around this atom.
And that's where it gets
philosophically interesting.
So you cannot describe an
electron's path around a
nucleus with the traditional
orbit idea that we've
encountered when we look at
planets or if we just imagine
things at kind of
a larger scale.
It turns out that an electron,
you cannot know exactly its
momentum and location at any
given point in time.
All you can know is a
probability distribution of
where it is likely to be.
And the way they depicted
this, black is a higher
probability, so you're much
more likely to find the
electron here than
you are here.
But the electron really
could be anywhere.
It could even to be here, even
though it's completely white
there, with some very, very,
very, very, very low
probability.
And so this function of where an
electron is, this is called
an orbital.
Orbital.
Not to be confused with orbit.
Remember, an orbit was
something like this.
It's like Venus going
around the Sun.
So it's very physically easy
for us to imagine.
While an orbital is actually
a mathematical probability
function that tells
us where we're
likely to find an electron.
We'll deal a lot more with that
when we cover quantum
mechanics, but that's not going
to be in the scope of
this kind of introductory set
of chemistry lectures.
But it's interesting, right?
An electron's behavior is so
bizarre at that scale that you
can't-- I mean, to call it a
particle is almost misleading.
It is called a particle, but
it's not a particle in the
sense that we're used to
in our everyday life.
It's this thing that you can't
even say exactly where it is.
It can be anywhere
in this haze.
And we'll learn later that there
are different shapes of
the hazes is as we add more and
more electrons to an atom.
But to me, it starts to address
philosophical issues
of what matter even is, or do
the things we look at, how
real are they?
Or how real are they, at least
as we've defined reality?
Anyway I don't want to get
too philosophical on you.
But the whole notion of
electrons, protons, they're
all kind of predicated on
this notion of charge.
And we've talked about it before
when we learned about
Coulomb's law.
You could review Coulomb's laws
videos in the physics
playlist. But the idea
is that an electron
has a negative charge.
A proton, sometimes
written like that,
has a positive charge.
And a neutron has no charge.
And so that's what was tempting
about the original
model of an electron.
If they say, OK, if this thing
has positive charges, right?
So let's say this is two
neutrons and two protons.
Let's say it's a helium atom.
Then we'll have some positive
charges here.
We have some negative
charges out here.
Opposite charges attract.
And so if these things had
some velocity, enough
velocity, they would orbit
around this, just the way a
planet will orbit
around the Sun.
But now we learn, even though
this is partially true, that
the further away an electron is
from the nucleus, it does
have more, it's true,
potential energy.
In that it will want to move
towards the nucleus, but
because of all the mechanics at
the quantum level, it won't
just do something simple like
move in a path like that, like
a comet would do around the Sun,
it actually has this kind
of wave-like behavior, where it
just has this probability
function that describes it.
But the further away
an orbital, it
does have more potential.
We're going to go a lot more
into that in future videos.
But anyway, how do you recognize
what an element is?
I've talked a lot about the
philosophy and all of that,
but how do I know that
this is helium?
Is it by the number of
neutrons it has?
Is it by the number
of protons it has?
of electrons?
Well the answer is, it's by
the number of protons.
So if you know the number of
protons in an element, you
know what that element is.
And the number of protons,
this is defined
as the atomic number.
Now, so let's say I said
something has four protons.
How do we know what it is?
Well if we haven't memorized it,
we could look it up on the
periodic table of elements,
which we'll be dealing with a
lot in this playlist. And you'd
say, oh, four protons,
that is beryllium.
Right there.
And the atomic number is the
number that you see up there.
And that' s literally the
number of protons.
And that is what differentiates
one atom from another.
If you have fifteen protons,
you're dealing with
phosphorus.
And all of a sudden, if you
have seven protons, you're
dealing with nitrogen.
If you have eight, you're
dealing with oxygen.
That is what defines
the element.
Now, we'll talk in the future
about what happens with charge
and all of that.
Or what happens when you
gain or lose electrons.
But that does not change what
element you're dealing with.
And likewise, when you change
the number of neutrons, that
also does not change the element
you're dealing with.
But that leads to an obvious
question of, well, how many
neutrons and electrons
do you have?
Well, if an atom is
charge-neutral, that means it
has the same number
of electrons.
So let's say that
I have carbon.
Its atomic number is six.
And let's say its mass
number is twelve.
Now what does this mean?
And let me say further that this
is a neutral particle.
This is a neutral atom.
So the atomic number
for carbon is six.
That tells us exactly how
many protons it has.
So if I were to draw a little
model here, and this is in no
way an accurate model.
I'll draw six-- two, three,
four, five, six
protons in the center.
And the weight of these protons,
each proton is one
atomic mass unit, and we'll
talk more about how that
relates to kilograms.
It's a very small
fraction of a kilogram.
Roughly I think it's
1.6 times 10 to the
minus 27th of a kilogram.
So let's say each of these are
one atomic mass unit, and
that's approximately equal to,
I think, 1.67 times 10 to the
minus 27 kilograms. This
is a very small number.
It's actually almost impossible
to visualize.
At least it is for me.
This tells me the mass of the
entire carbon atom, of this
particular carbon atom.
And this can actually
change from carbon
atom to carbon atom.
And this is essentially the
mass of all of the protons
plus all of the neutrons.
And each proton has an atomic
mass of one, in atomic mass
units, and each neutron
has an atomic mass of
one atomic mass unit.
So this is really the number
of protons plus
the number of neutrons.
So in this case we have six
protons, so we must also have
six neutrons.
Six neutrons plus six protons.
Now, where are the electrons?
Well, I said it's neutral, so
the proton has an equal
positive charge as the
electron's negative charge.
So this is a neutral atom, and
it has six protons, so it also
has six electrons.
Let me draw that.
So we said it has six
neutrons in here.
One, two, three, four,
five, six.
So that's the nucleus
right there.
And then if we were to draw the
electons-- well, I could
draw it as a smear, but if we
want to kind of visualize it a
little better, we could say,
OK, there's going to be six
electrons orbiting.
One, two, three, four,
five, six.
And they're going to be moving
around in this unpredictable
way that we would have
to describe with
a probability function.
And so the interesting thing
about it is, most of the mass
of an atom is sitting
right in here.
I mean, you might notice that
when people care about the
mass, when they care about the
atomic mass number of an atom,
they ignore the electrons.
And that's because the mass
of a proton, one proton
mass-wise, is equal
to 1,836 electons.
So for thinking about the mass
of an atom, for all basic
purposes, you can ignore the
mass of an electron.
It's really the mass of the
nucleus that counts as the
mass of the atom.
Now, you might see this periodic
table here, and you
say, OK, they gave us the
atomic number up there.
The atomic number of
oxygen is eight.
It means it has eight protons.
The atomic number of
silicon is 14.
It has 14 protons.
Now what is this right here?
Let's see, in carbon.
In carbon they have
this 12.0107.
That is the atomic
weight of carbon.
Let me write this.
Atomic weight of carbon.
The atomic weight of
carbon is 12.0107.
Now, what does that mean?
Does that mean that carbon has
six protons and then the
remainder, the remaining 6.0107
neutrons, it has kind
of this fraction of a neutron?
No.
It means if you were to average
all the different
versions of carbon you find on
the planet and you were to
average the number of neutrons
based on the quantity of the
different types of carbon,
this is the
average you would get.
So it turns out that carbon, the
two major forms, the main
one you'll find is carbon-12.
So that's like this.
So that has six protons
and six neutrons.
And then another isotope
of carbon.
Now an isotope is the same
element with a different
number of neutrons.
Another isotope of carbon is
carbon-14, which is much more
scarce on the planet.
We don't know how much in the
universe, but on the planet.
Now, if you were to average
these, not just a straight-up
average, then you would get
carbon-13 and then the atomic
weight would be 13, but you
weight this one much higher
because this exists in much
larger quantities on Earth.
I mean, this is pretty
much all of the
carbon that you see.
But there's a little
bit of this.
So if you weight them
appropriately, the average
becomes this.
So most of the carbon you'll
find-- if you just found
carbon someplace, on average
its weight in atomic mass
units is going to be 12.0107.
But that idea of an isotope
is an interesting one.
Remember, when you change the
neutrons, you're not changing
the actual, fundamental
element.
You're just getting a different
isotope, a different
version, of the element.
So these two versions of carbon
are both isotopes.
Now, I want to leave this video
with what I think is
kind of the neatest idea behind
atoms. And it's the
most philosophically interesting
things about them.
It's that the relative size--
so, we have these electrons,
which represent very little
of the mass of an atom.
It's 1/2000 of the mass of an
atom are the electrons.
And even those, it's hard
to even describe them as
particles, because you can't
even tell me exactly where and
how fast one of these
particles is moving.
They just have a probability
function.
So most of the atom is sitting
inside the nucleus.
And this is the interesting
thing.
If you look at an atom
on average, if you
say this is my atom.
Let's say I had two atoms that
are bonded to each other.
And I were to say, how much
of this is actual stuff?
And when I say stuff, that's a
very abstract concept, because
we're talking about the
nucleus, right?
Because the nucleus
is where all the
mass is, all the stuff.
It turns out that it's actually
an infinitesimally
small fraction of the volume of
the atom where-- the volume
of the atom is hard to define,
because the electron can
pretty much be anywhere, but
if you view the volume as
where you're most likely to find
the electron, or with 90%
probability you're likely to
find the electron, then the
nucleus is, in a lot of cases
and the way I think about it,
it's about 1/10,000
of the volume.
So if you think about it, when
you look at something, if you
look at your hand or if you
look at the wall or if you
look at your computer, 99.999%
of it is free space.
It's nothing.
It's vacuum.
If you had ultra-small-- I
guess we could call them
particles or something-- most
of them would pass straight
through whatever you look at.
So it already starts to kind of
question our hold on reality.
What is there when, if-- and
this is fact, this isn't
theory right here-- that if you
take anything down to the
building blocks, down to the
atomic level, most of the
space of that kind of,
quote-unquote object, is free
vacuum space.
You could go straight through
it if you could get down to
that scale.
This image of a helium atom,
they say right here this is
one femtometer.
Right?
One femtometer.
This is the scale of
the nucleus of a
helium atom, right?
One femtometer.
This is one angstrom, right?
And they say that equals
100,000 femtometers.
And just to get a sense of
scale, one angstrom is 1 times
10 to the negative
10 meters, right?
So the atom is roughly on the
scale of an angstrom.
In the case of helium,
the nucleus is
even a smaller fraction.
It's 1/100,000.
So if you had-- let's say you
had liquid helium, which you'd
have to get very cold to get.
If you're looking at that,
most of it is free space.
If you're looking at an iron
bar, the great, great, great,
great, great, great majority
of it is free space.
And we're not even talking
about, maybe there's some free
space inside the nucleus
that we could talk
about in the future.
But to me, that just blows my
mind that most things we look
at are not really solid.
They're really just empty space,
but they look solid
because of the way light
reflects on them or the forces
that repel us.
But there really isn't something
to touch there.
That most of this right here
is all free space.
I think I've said the word free
space now, and I think
I'll leave further
mind-blowing to the next video.